why does the US jail more people than
any other country
one reason mandatory minimums these were
introduced in the 1980s and apply to
low-level crimes mandatory minimums mean
convicted people have to serve a minimum
sentence whether or not a judge thinks
they deserve it for example drug crimes
involving crack heroin or marijuana
trigger minimum sentences so do crimes
involving firearms pornography and
immigration but opponents say the
punishment doesn't always fit the crime
take the story of Kemba Smith an
unemployed woman who moved in with her
drug dealer boyfriend after he was
murdered she was charged with conspiracy
to traffic all the drugs he left behind
mandatory minimum sentence 24 years in
another case John Horner a 46 year old
fast-food worker with prescription
painkillers met a friend who wanted some
of his pills the friend turned out to be
an undercover agent conviction for drug
trafficking 25-year minimum at 25
Timothy Tyler got caught selling LSD
with his dad because he had been caught
selling twice before the mandatory
sentence life since mandatory minimums
were imposed there's been a 500%
increase in the incarcerated population
at a cost of 80 billion dollars to run
the prison system is it time for
mandatory minimums to end